[Music]
welcome to the ultimate
iphone 12 pro max camera review
what in the world is going on here we're
testing iphone cameras
including this beast of a phone the 1099
iphone 12 pro max but what makes this
promax crazy isn't just its gigantic 6.7
inch screen
but it's three cameras which are the
best yet from apple
just look at this camera bump there's a
new telephoto camera that gives you more
zoom
and a whole new wide camera that lets in
more light
but just how much better are those new
cameras versus the cameras on the other
iphone 12 models and even some older
iphones
and what about in comparison to some new
android phones
so we recruited trina mary a body
painter and photographer
and asked her to create the ultimate
2020 portrait
to help me test these cameras
[Music]
oh yeah that's nicholas universo he's
really good at standing still
i've set up three different photo test
scenarios if you want to see the
differences
feel free to pause the video and if
you're wondering about everything else
in these iphones
i've already reviewed that it's these
photos that you have to see
you ready to do this 2020 iphone
portrait man do i have a choice
not really test one portrait shots
all of the iphone 12 models have new
wide cameras
the 12 pro max has an even better sensor
than the others
but we'll get to that soon all of the
wide cameras let you shoot portrait mode
shots
where the software artfully blurs the
background so your subject stands out
i used the wide camera for this shot
with all four iphone 12 models
can't spot the difference there really
isn't any in daylight these wide cameras
are nearly indistinguishable
although it's a big improvement from the
iphone 10. oof
look at those colors and actually i
preferred the google pixel 5's color
representation of this scene the best
what makes the iphone 12 pro and pro max
better portrait cams
are their telephoto cameras the pro
max's telephoto takes it even further
it has a longer 65 millimeter focal
length lens
that's capable of 2.5 x optical zoom
translation a more intimate and flatter
image
where the background is closer it feels
like something a portrait lens on a dslr
would turn out
one other place this telephoto is really
nice video
all the iphone 12 models record dolby
hdr video
you look like van gaal right now we're
gonna need something to cut his ear off
when you watch it back on an hdr display
it looks stunning
the iphone 12 pro max is nice to have
you can still take some great portrait
shots with 12 pro
there's two ultra wide shots all of
these have the same ultrawide cameras
the shots are a bit crisper and a little
less distorted than last year's iphone
11 models
but you have to be looking really
carefully
oh and one of the coolest things on the
iphone pro max going from capturing this
all the way out to capturing this
takeaway here it doesn't matter what
phone you buy for ultra wide shots
s3 selfies uh no actually
it's night shots let's return now to
those wide cameras
on the iphone 12 mini 12 and 12 pro
these have been improved with a wider
aperture of f 1.6
that lets in 27 more light than the wide
camera on the iphone 11.
the performance is impressive especially
compared to an older iphone 10
10r or iphone se here's another shot
where you can see the difference big
time
the promaxx's wide camera however has a
wider aperture
and a larger sensor so it lets an 87
percent more light
where you can tell the difference is in
basically dark conditions
is it an insane difference no but you
can see it
especially when you compare to these
android phones and because it lets in
more light
the pro max doesn't turn on night mode
as frequently that's the setting that
uses a combination of hardware and
software to brighten the shots
when it does kick in night mode it
requires you to stay still for less time
making the shots less blurry the wide
camera on both the 12 pro and the pro
max
also uses the new lidar sensor to help
take nice
night shot portraits so what's the final
picture
well the iphone pro max has a fabulous
set of cameras and gives you a lot more
flexibility than the iphone 12 the
iphone mini and even the iphone 12 pro
but don't buy this phone just for all of
that this phone is insanely large
which sucks for those of us who like
smaller phones because we don't get as
good of a camera
of course what we really saw here today
is that the other 12 models take
really good photos too especially the
smaller pro with its telephoto camera
or you could wait it out apple has a
long track record of introducing its
best camera features on the high end
models
and then expanding them across the line
either way
you know what they say the best camera
is the one that you have with you
when you happen upon a living breathing
portrait
i think i saw this phone on steve jobs
conference back in 2008